she didn't have to rely on their agent
to get some work Chevy ocean yeah I hurt
my agent so I'm screwed I think that no
I think that an agent and in this
business is a is a great commodity to
have you know what you're going to say
necessary evil now with the words you
can you know I think that that agents
can in the agents that work well that
are you know good at their job they get
you opportunities you know they get you
into rooms and they can they pitch you
and they talk to the people to producers
and casting directors mostly to you know
get you seen review for these auditions
um that being said i would say that
eighty-five percent of my work that I do
in my career has been on gone away on
just from relationships and and you know
there's so many small movies being made
now that people just gonna call up and
say hey making those movies you know
come on a grand is it going to be a lot
of police chases in it and the police
will maybe come after you and I could
see it right now right I feel like I'm
there and sometimes just imagine that
it's absolutely really just paint a real
picture sonic Lance can use just the
natural soundtrack look you do treat it
well it's good job what does that work
involved let's suppose you're going
through a down period where works not
coming in mm-hmm maybe nothing's no
emails from the agent alcohol so what
type of things do both due to draw them
up work yourselves well i right I prefer
not work so I'm just when the phone is
not running I've gotta get out of the
way maybe you should move out of the way
and maybe get out of way so ya want to
work they could take those jobs yeah
yeah take a bottle think about that for
a second book a job you like hey I'll
pass give it to Joe you give to Joey
I'll take it yeah I get up all right now
Chris's job
z for the ice Aaron yes I was on the
ground for the your jobs always in the
ground picture um would you ask so what
what types of things do you know what do
you do he doing the drama work oh you
write out big drum no I i right you know
I think that I go out and do some
stand-up now and then just to kind of
like to be and get up and and and just
perform you know so stand up helps or do
him bro a little bit take class you know
just to kind of keep my motor running
but in terms of drumming on my homework
beyond writing and things like that I
just relationships you know I'm just
kind of thing out and and going to
screenings and film festivals are great
when we get to the fun festivals you
mean a lot of like cool filmmakers and
people are you know and the same kind of
on the same path as you see you know
exchange information and get to know
people that way what do you do you just
don't come to any of those things that
you just mentioned but sounds good it
sounds like that's probably the right
answer to give ya if you are contrasting
answers which would be his answer versus
my answer it's a much much better answer
your answer my answer is just kind of
master this kind of like
but you also i would like dude like a
half when you stop by your agents use a
city vibrator yeah i don't have an agent
how did you get this last job I've
manager okay that's good mentoring it
puts you sometimes you have to like you
have to stop by your agents and your
managers and kind of put your face in I
think it's been about four years since
I've seen my manager last face to face
these series yeah you know I'm just not
very I don't do this thing out divet
Witter account not a relative managers
office I don't know I should probably do
it I probably should get to work on
these things I just hate doing it can't
stand it I like to live in the delusion
that that that working you know doing
good work at the moment as best you can
it's the important thing but that's
probably totally bullshitting mr. image
I think that yeah I think that you have
to do more than more than that yeah oh
well oh well Twitter here I come maybe I
should tweet my engine right now hey I
fire dude hey agent tweet on this
wouldn't even tweet what do I say in a
tweet hey guys getting interviewed right
now I get that's what I could I could
tweet be like yeah you're right i'm
doing injured with her own courage don't
all get a check it out can't you just
tweet this video put this video on a
tweet tweet this tweet this people would
love that yeah should have a shirt that
says tweet this it's got an arrow
pointing down to your dick yeah I should
we did good should have no why don't
have that it's kind of an injustice I
don't have that shirt yet yet being the
key word give me a few days kids and I
should enemy don't have the shirt but I
will have it written in sharpie on my
chest they're probably misspelled oh yes
certainly it should be like backwards
cuz im looking in the mirror we to smell
tweet what is this man cut this
with this
you